mais d'abord cinq milliards d'euros de
surcoût un 'trou d'air' colossales chez
eads on tente de relativiser
au lendemain de l'annoncé d'un nouveau
retard de livraison d'un an des a380
pourtant le plan de restructuration
d'airbus annoncé dans la foulée est
censée compenser les pertes fait
craindre en france comme en allemagne de
graves conséquences sociales et
industrielles ont fait le point avec
laurence ragon l'a380 un avion de rêve
qui tourne au cauchemar
il devait sortir des chaînes à la fin de
l'année finalement un seul et unique
exemplaire sera livré en octobre 2007
deux ans de retard pour faire face à ce
coup financier eads impose un plan
d'économies réduction des coûts de 30%
ce qui n'exclut pas les suppressions
d'emplois on demande aux salariés de
payer l'addition
parce que les actionnaires ne veulent
pas d'à payer alors que cette addition
est à payer par les actionnaires parce
que c'est logique c'est leur politique
depuis cinq ans qui a amené ces
résultats qui a mené une étude allemand
cette situation d'échec dans son plan de
restructuration
eads ne donne aucune précision sur le
volet social
en revanche le groupe laisse entendre
qu'une réorganisation du circuit de
production seraient envisagées la
production est partagée notamment entre
la france et l'allemagne tout sera
remise à plat firme ne tombe dans une
communication très officielle de la ds
tout ceci sera fait en dialogue avec
l'ensemble des partenaires concernés et
nous savons bien que quand les efforts
doivent être faits chacun souhaite
qu'ils soient équitablement répartis
entre les différents pays partenaires et
membres de de ads
depuis des mois à hambourg ou à toulouse
les cadences sont au maximum sur les
chaînes d'airbus pour certains syndicats
pas question de bouleverser
l'organisation du travail je ne pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
déstabiliser une chaîne et qui tourne ce
serait une erreur tout à fait et
financières industrielles et même
sociale je ne crois pas aujourd'hui à
cette manoeuvre ce serait vraiment
aggraver la situation
du côté de la sous traitance airbus fait
vivre 50 mille salariés
certaines pme pourraient être touchés de
plein fouet par la restructuration
évidemment on est en concurrence avec
ces pays soient de l'est choix russie
chine inde etc
donc forcément on sera toujours pêcheurs
tout et ça s'ils veulent les ressorts à
son cou ils vont aller forcément
ailleurs que dans la zone france la
direction de eads se donne trois mois
avant de trancher un traitement de choc
est nécessaire pour rassurer les
compagnies aériennes déjà emirates
menace d'annuler une partie de ses
commandes d'a380